[Music]
it's xenon girl of the 21st century and
if you think that doesn't date it take a
listen to this president
Chelsea Clinton yep that's the kind of
on the nose writing we're gonna be
dealing with here
well okay looking at this maybe it's
supposed to be the late 21st century
that gives a bit of time 20 49 yeah
definitely optimism at the height of
foolishness but whatever it's children's
fiction what's the story well Xena a
tween each girl lives on a space station
and does all sorts of things that girl
that age usually does hang out with her
friends listen to bands get in trouble
all that stuff but when she sees that
the biggest funder of the space station
seems to be up to no good
she tries to call him out on it but
nobody believes her as punishment for
her actions she's grounded literally
she's grounded down to earth
which she barely remembers because she
left when she was in kindergarten as
you'd imagine Earth and the space
station are very different from one
another and she has a hard time fitting
in her Aunt Judy is a little odd the
clothes are all different people talk
different even the food and gravity are
off from what she's used to but slowly
over time she starts to make friends and
they start to realize maybe all those
things she was saying about the funder
was true as those evildoers tried to
track her down because she has some sort
of secret disc and ultimately she ends
up trying to save her space station
while also trying to get a dance with
her favorite boy band yeah it's pretty
silly it should probably imagine there
isn't really that much in this for
adults this is clearly made for a very
target audience of I don't know let's
say five to eleven year olds because of
this a lot of a storytelling acting is a
little over the top
but I have to admit when I was that age
this is the kind of acting and
storytelling I liked listening to it is
exaggerated there are a lot of catch
phrases but the film does try to
contribute a few interesting ideas and
fun environments the space station for
example it's a really cool design I just
love looking at I love these colors I
love these setups okay it looks a little
cheap but it's almost like being on Deep
Space nine except from the little kids
point of view I always thought that
became a neat idea but the nice thing is
the fun stuff doesn't stop when she
leaves the space station her
interactions on earth are actually kind
of interesting because she's not very
familiar with it she thinks everyone
constant
has to dodge tornadoes and earthquakes
and sicknesses and if someone grew up on
a space station that is probably what
they would assume they say that gravity
on earth compared to the space station
is also 30 pounds heavier and they
demonstrate this very cleverly by just
having your go on this bridge that's at
an angle and they tilt the camera and
that's a very simple way of showing it
but it's also really effective
there's also fun contrast like even
though she constantly gets into trouble
and can do all these cool things on the
space station she's afraid of horses
she's known as a risk-taker back at home
but she's terrified of trying a burger
she even has good comebacks for these
stereotypical bullies seeing how people
on earth and Space Station is dressed
different this one girl goes up to her
and asked if she's gonna be in a freak
show or dressing up for Halloween
her response you win now lend me that
mask you're wearing and I'll have the
most hideous major costume ever oh I
love that you think she's gonna go
through the whole movie just with her
head down looking sad and stuff but no
the first insult she gets she throws it
right back I love that they played
around with that a little bit but on top
of that it has a clever way of
demonstrating a very familiar lesson it
is a fish out of water story and about
adapting but it's a kind of adapting
that a lot of kids that age can
understand it's moving from one location
to another where the clothes are
different and the language is different
and tiny things you took for granted can
suddenly get you in a lot of trouble but
by adding that extra element of having
it in the future and on a space station
it makes it a little bit more
interesting it's more fun than creative
even if sometimes the effects are pretty
laughably bad come on these were
embarrassing even by the standards back
to that but while the effects don't look
that great they do still take the time
to have a character be in a moment while
the characters don't look like they're
really there they feel like they're
really there the movie takes time to
just focus on their reaction and play
some nice music and feel the environment
and they give the same thing on earth to
where you can appreciate the ocean and
landscapes and such I think this movie
knows what's gonna be fun about it is
the environment then they let you as a
kid enjoy it is a cliched sure can the
characters get annoying sometimes but a
few imaginative ideas and visuals mixed
with even a few good performances
from the boyfriend in the end give it a
nice enough atmosphere where if I was
the appropriate age they were aiming for
I would probably enjoy it not much in it
for adults but I don't really think it's
meant for adults it's meant for kids who
need to learn about being out of place
but also about accepting new ideas and
new environments
Bendis does have some imaginative ideas
and environments
what's adults but fall asleep but I
think most kids would have a cheesy but
fun time
[Music]
[Applause]
you